i wanted to kick it off by acknowledging
someone i found out was
a childhood idol we have a picture
yes that was like the main reason i
picked up drumsticks
i loved that so much because
i was such a fan too growing up
and we're both born i believe 1975
yes and you have kids yours are older
though
yeah so i have three kids i have my
youngest daughter
alabama's 15 my son landon is 17
and then my oldest daughter atiana is 21
who um i've raised since she was two
years old
and yeah i i my kids are
seve almost seven and almost nine and
this is such a tricky time
for kids that age with school and a year
long of home school
yeah i mean you just gotta think of the
positives that we get to spend so much
time with them and
kind of like not worry about the hustle
of taking them to school and bringing
them back home from school
so that's been really really awesome
um just by default and then just taking
this time to like learn something new or
like thrive and
and kind of dig deep like i started
producing a ton during this time
so there's just been like blessings upon
blessings that have happened during this
time as well
being a producer i think that you know
i i believe that i'm still around
because
i got involved behind the scenes did you
think like that was it conscious or
did you just love what you did and knew
so much about it that you
like what was what was your catalyst for
wanting to
take on more for me i obviously was like
really into playing the drums and being
the best drummer i could
and it was constantly practicing but i
felt like
i always had this this longing and this
desire to help
arrange the music or not have a bridge
like i was i was always
uh so active and giving my input and all
that and then
that really really came to petition when
i was in blink
and you know in the middle of the state
was our groundbreaking album that really
was an essential album for us and i
think that was the first one i got to
write and help arrange and
really be a part of the songwriting and
that from that point on i knew that
that was something i wanted to do and i
had like a talent besides just playing
drums
well then there's another side of it
where you're like okay i am this thing
i love everything about it i live my
life through it but then you grow
and you change and you want to get
involved and i love branding i love
advertising i love
creating things and so there's also more
than
not only so many things in one aspect
there's more than just the one aspect of
people and you
have started this wellness line barker
wellness and
um will you tell us about it it's
beautiful by the way
oh thank you you know i love vigorous
touring in that schedule playing
six to seven shows a week for you know
sometimes
15 weeks at a time recovery became like
a big issue for me just figuring out
this
does epsom salt fast work does
cryotherapy work for me does
cbd work for me and i just started
really really
experimenting with it all and i found
that cbd was like a big
big big you know helpful um
recovery um tool for for touring and
and just recovery after exercising
and two years later barker wellness was
born
i just basically did it because i was
using all this product and it was such
it was so helpful it was life-changing i
i
wanted to ask you because you do just
have such an incredible
attitude i feel like i don't know i just
relate to you in a lot of ways we've
both
been living out there you know
with our lives sort of like open book
style
having kids reacting to that as parents
do you like i'm also like a doberman
with my kids because of my
upbringing how are you with your kids
with like you know your advice of
having them be out there or not so
my kids have been touring with me since
they were two so
i think i can't protect them from
everything i can't shelter them from
everything
all i can do is kind of you know show
them what doors i walked through and
what worked for me and what didn't work
for me
and um you know protect them and guide
them as much as i can
i love your answer and i read a
note that your lovely lady wrote to you
saying like
we may destroy each other and
i was like oh that's so hot and i think
my love note might be like can we just
get to bed early
and like watch a movie
yeah i would i would prefer the opposite
i would prefer to
you know kind of go and blaze glory
like ball of flames now i'm dating again
i i i had a weird question and if you're
not comfortable talking about it forget
it but
i wanted to ask advice which is like if
you date someone and you have children
do you think it's better to date someone
with kids
and then they'll understand your life or
say it doesn't matter
if they don't have kids then you can
like have fun adventures and just like
you know kind of get out of that mind
frame
so i've done both like up until now like
i would
you know like date girls that didn't
have kids and i find it
kind of hard because they would i think
they would have trouble understanding
like well why
why don't you want to go to dinner every
night with me or why don't you want to
see me every night
and now i'm
you know spending time with a woman
who's like a great mom
who's like a great friend and
i just you don't have to worry about any
of those things it just
comes natural it's like a maturity thing
yeah and uh
and i also really like missing someone
and and
cherishing the time that i spend with
them instead of you know every day being
with them
or especially in the beginning of the
relationship
i i think like missing someone so
important
yep it's so true
you